did you know that this Friday is
National Picnic Day and we love a picnic
moment with spring soirees and full
swing why not host a fun picnic themed
Soiree joining us now is to share some
of his must-haves for National Picnic
Day and all your other spring parties is
entertaining expert Paul's on welcome
back thanks for having me it is so good
to have you I always love what you bring
and
sprung
here tell us what you brought for us
okay so first up we have a Parisian
picnic perfect charcuterie bite so in
order to have the perfect charcuterie
bite you need to have creamy crunchy
sweet Savory and salty in each bite so
that's what I did here I crafted these
here we have some blueberries we have
some crackers we have some cheese and
then we have some Columbus craft Meats
delicious Italian salami Columbus craft
Meats has been doing charcuterie for
over a hundred years they know a thing
or two about charcuterie so you can go
to their website columbuscraftmeets.com
to find out some more recipes they use
premium full cuts of meat absolutely
delicious so that's our Parisian picnic
situation well that looks lovely and
then you've got to throw in drink this
one cocktail right we have some ESPN
tequila and I crafted a delicious skinny
margarita right here so espanita is a
delicious tequila that's 100 blue Weber
Agave it is double distilled and this is
the blanco perfect for Paloma it's great
for margaritas but they also have a
double barrel that's aged in both um
French Oak and American Oaks so it's got
a nice flavor profile it Mellows out
that tequila perfect for Cinco de Mayo
and you can pick this up at Lee's
Liquors I love it
with this one you can use it as a straw
do you think that you could use the Red
Vines as a saw and I also crafted a fun
little popcorn party mix right here with
some popcorn some Red Vines and some
sour punch you know Red Vines a
delicious licorice they have the black
licorice they have the regular delicious
licorice it's low sodium kosher and
they're all about peace love and Vines
this time of year it's really about
celebrating everybody and sharing
stories getting together and sharing
stories and then sour punch we love the
delicious the sour the sweet everything
like that and they have embrace your
punch that's celebrating everyone no
matter where you come from what you do
everything just everybody coming
together and celebrating so so far are
this is the best pick Nick ever
um but then we have this here tell us
about this so you know for a fun idea
for a Mother's Day gift or a picnic
party you could grab a picnic basket on
Amazon and fill it with goodies for Mom
or fill it for your guests so we have
some blissy pillowcases so this is a
hundred percent Mulberry silk it's soft
like butter it's going to help with your
hair not break when you sleep it's going
to help get rid of those wrinkles or
prevent wrinkles it's a game changer and
with 85 000 verified five star reviews
online I mean you can't beat that so you
can go to blissey.com to find out more
information about blissy and you know
put it in that picnic basket if you want
to take a nap during that picnic
blissey's got you covered well you know
what's funny I actually have this exact
brand okay it really is a great one I
can go for like three nights without
washing my hair it's perfect I sleep
with it so soft the best stuff thank you
so much thank you you really know how to
throw a soir right